allez vas-y premier beau alors darker
elle est super g l et c'est qu'avec tu
rigoles paris canal comme j'aime bien le
chien très bien le bateau race rare mais
grave parce que souvent la mère n est
pas bien elle est démontée et j'ai le
mal de mer donc pas bien dark à tous
va-t-on voir à ce canal j'aime pas ah
non non si gyan
il ya une espèce de gros les arbres
comme ça un chemin quand on s'appelle un
truc énorme et les choix qui l'animent
qui beaucoup chaque fois qu'ils me
voyaient toujours en train de faire des
petites léchouilles j'aime pas trop bon
donc voila mais selon le son parfait
roland garros le monde contrefous hasek
le patron
le boss alors pour le boss c'est dark à
regarder ce corps de rêve donc d'aircal
formidable aux cadors les mycoses
formidable zarka pour la mycose d'arcade
braschaat pourquoi je sais pas ah ça
c'est bien ça
ça chauffe donc l'afrique en restant
alors ras sera aussi [ __ ] je me ferais
j'aime bien alors j'aime bien parce que
quand c'est dans la nuit pitié qu'ils
quittaient leur titre ça fait du bruit
tu as peur et il fait des papes quick
après qu'il eut donc juste pour sa
j'adore
[Musique]